it's craving time reject Nation we are joined by
John John how are you I am craving this trailer
Coy you are sweaty because I called you when
you're at the gym getting a pump on time to
get a pump and some Sony on it's commitment right
there ladies and Gentlemen please go ahead leave
a like on this video that would mean a lot there's
a couple things I want to mention if you miss our
flash spoiler talk on Saturday we announced that
we are going to be having a Comic-Con panel a real
rejects Comic-Con panel Saturday July 22nd just
a few hours before Marvel more details to come
sooner rather than later secondly this video is
sponsored by a drink that I'm drinking right now
G fuel if you look at my fridge you'll see that
I've got so much G fuel in there look at that the
reason I want to shout them out in this video
is because everyone grab a tub they have these
spider-verse exclusive flavors right now and if
you use code reject Nation get 20 off select tubs
right now I'm drinking the one in John's hand and
it is delicious you guys know I'm obsessed with G
fuel these two love G fuel they're constantly
stealing it from me and I say fine whatever I
guess I'll be a nice employer today but seriously
G Phil you know how much I love you you guys got
to know by this point I'm always drinking it
even when they're not in a sponsored post s
[Music]
oh it's a Sony movie spider verse my son
never show Mercy plus a pro they are playing
the Predators I love that Russell Crowe
agreed to do this your mother is dead
she died because you sent her away she
was weak sick in her mind a chameleon
business oh is it on the left yeah Power
is about strength if you show weakness
give our enemies an opening befriend it shot
lioness are in it that becomes his vest or does it
fake like his mother leave him what happened that
day what what it's Chris he's like Charlie Sheen
he's got Tiger Blood The Lion for the first time
I saw my true self and he doesn't have an accent
tell me about this Hunter uses a connection with
animals to track his prey once you're on his list
there's only one way off here's a radioactive
line there's six of you now [Music]
okay okay
[Music]
you are you're saving this hunting for
a trophy murderers is not what he taught
Callisto you don't get to do that
to me anymore [Music] all the jacket
Mr tackling where's Mr tagline
oh you're standing in him
you're a goddamn lunatic oh
you just figured that out now
yeah
let's go
interesting last time there is an animal in each
one of us don't you want to know why they call me
the Rhino whoa what damn we're getting like an
actual Rhino it's gonna turn into a rhino yeah
I mean so this is not in The Amazing Spider-Man
universe ah spider versus okay that felt like
typical Sony Marvel trailer I was like oh God
we're going down this path again the second
blood and gore and violence started happening
I forgot we were watching a red band trailer
for a second and then I was like this this is all
you needed to do this whole time yeah prevent him
and morbius if you're gonna go like Sony Marvel
schlock at least just make it violent and they
listen they listen Dave the trailer entirely for
me and suddenly went from oh God it's radioactive
lion it is he doesn't have an accent too yes yes
yes yes yes yes and there and Taylor Johnson's
looking badass this is great yeah that trailer uh
had a full 360 spin that was that was a journey
for me that was an emotional journey and he like
he looks great in like the full lion um what the
hell is that called Sylvester just a vest it's the
lion fur right yeah it's got the main on it yeah
uh yeah I I like the trailer I did not expect
to have that experience of [__] too hell yeah
all right Johnny please take it away yeah I
absolutely agree I think it's smart of them
to build on their like you know kind of goofy-ish
but fun sort of 90s quality by making it that much
more of an exploitation movie I love the all all
the different animals and stuff and watching as
he takes on different properties of the animal
kingdom to hunt down human beings and for animal
lovers out there I have to imagine this will be
a very cathartic movie because you're just gonna
watch a Murk a ton of terrible people and I know
they changed bits of his character and what not
being the hunter now to being sort of a protector
a commuter with animals yeah I want to call bits
of changes changes the origin but at the same time
I'm kind of here for that and I think you know
somebody who represents and fights for and with
the animal kingdom is a badass ideas yeah this
looks awesome and there are Taylor Jobs it looks
great he does look great I am liking the way it's
shot too it looks better than morbius like the the
cinematography I'm talking about specifically the
lighting looks sharper cleaner and I like the
variation between the jungle and the different
environments and all that so yeah but koi had to
know that was chameleon okay so his little brother
Dimitri is who chameleon is in the comic books
it's a half brother uh he's usually seen as more
small and slight and blonde so that to the left
is in the car uh later when he's reintroduced he's
going to be someone I assume that is uh basically
siding with Craven but something puts them at odds
maybe like a trail from the father at one point he
says in the trailer you look just like father so I
think there's going to be like that undercurrent
of family and Legacy and maybe they're fighting
over the Legacy what I find most interesting is
they not only introduce Callisto in this which is
huge in the torment Saga which is Todd McFarlane's
first solo writing and illustrating Ron on
Spider-Man I was introducing like 1990 Spider-Man
number one Callisto come on I'm getting there
but it's very iconic imagery used in the torment
uh Saga that they put in here the spider's coming
down is not only introduced in the torment Saga
but also it is in Craven's last hunt now this is
obviously not going to touch on craving the last
hunt but allowing that industry I don't want it to
touch on Craven's life we want it together no we
hate the best stories last time we hate that he's
a hunter if you introduce in the beginning those
those images and those uh hallucinations I think
will be a really good way to have the potion come
into play to have him start to lose his mind and
I'm thinking that's going to tie into how we fight
Spider-Man so what I think this is going to be is
they've got Rhino who is in this case transforming
I think instead of having him put in a suit that
he's stuck in he's going to transform too many
times he gets stuck as the Rhino which would
be an interesting conversation about like him
poaching poachers and him hunting animals and this
man who's using an animal power to take out humans
interesting commentary there but also it might be
something with the chameleon where chameleon can
transform his skin so I'm wondering if something
happens that is the Rhino's powers that allows
chameleon to use his powers or if he influences
the Rhino but I think all of that ties in with
Callisto who has the ability to cause these
potions and to have all these African herbs that
give Craven bigger Powers but it that's his mind
so I think Callisto is going to be either the big
bad or cause the big bad in the film so showing
her in the trailers are interesting and allowing
that to lead to the greater spider-verse and using
the sound design from across the spider-verse a
lot of those sounds and horns and things I think
are all going to make a bigger web I agree with 50
of what you're saying that's fair I think you are
you have some great theories there of where this
will ultimately lead to and I feel like a lot of
times you pitch these ideas that are often way
better than what we get I should be higher have
said that you ought to have been you ought to be
hired many people have expressed that sentiment
because I would use it as chameleon being Rhino as
a commentary on this brotherly rivalry and that's
why his power set is different and then that it's
a big reveal in betrayal so the expectation the
audience is as Rhino but that would actually tie
to his power set but I think they'll just actually
be involved so they have more toys that's what
I mean but uh thank you for all the information
there um that was great that was excellent It's
Gonna be great this year but the fact that he's
going to be also in Marvel Spider-Man 2. where
we're going to get a more accurate version of
craving over but at least we got this we got two
versions of crib we got this version of Craven
and then we're gonna have the accurate version
represented in Marvel Spider-Man 2. uh so yeah I
mean I was really surprised by this I really
liked it a lot I liked it a lot more than I
expected he looks great man it's JC shondor tooted
through uh triple Frontier as well I really like
this director I think it is going to tie into the
legacy of family and all those things and I think
uh casting Russell Crowe is going to be a really
Powerhouse moving parts of the transformation with
Rhino that look that'll remind me of like Amazing
Spider-Man one specifically yeah yeah absolutely
um but hey guys uh I love and look at this
I'm loving the violence loving the gore I'm a
simple man to please when it comes to this lower
expectations that I'm more than satisfied that's
how we do this what did you guys think about
the trailer were you surprised by it leave your
thoughts down below thank you koi for rushing on
over here from the gym he sprinted from Hollywood
to the area I live in uh subscribe leave a
like click that Bell last one Lisa Simpsons
I want to shout out Omni media Michael B today
because I'm sure right now he is doing exactly
what we're doing hustling to get his trailer
reaction up here on the YouTubes and he is one
of the best reactors and my personal opinion
who's out there I feel like he should be way
more popular than all of us especially
koi I think he should be exceptionally
more popular and one of these days do when you
move out to California I promise you I'm hiring
your ass and you're just going to join here and
replace someone one of the people in this video
Roxy strong
see you guys [Music]